whoa I am totally like in the matrix and
stuff this is crazy ones and zeros and I
can see the future the future of video
games it's it's digital what are you
doing why are you in my shot why are you
seeing the future video games digital
all video games to digital well well
actually pong was analog but that's not
important right now okay I don't mean
the future of video games or digital the
future video game distribution is
digital none of this go to a store and
buy a game in a plastic box crap the
future is games on demand right in the
comfort of your very own home is that
what today's game life is about oh well
today's game life is going to be about
the history of matrix games but your
idea sounds a lot better
did you know that you can download video
games on your video game console right
from the comfort of your own home a lot
of people don't but Xbox 360 Playstation
3 and the we all have services that let
you do just that but even though every
video game company knows they've got to
be in this business because it's the
future not all of them quite know what
they're doing just yet and that's why
today we're going to rate all three of
the digital download services if for no
other reason than rating things ticks
off fanboys now if you're talking about
downloading games on consoles you've got
to start with Xbox Live Arcade
Microsoft's games on demand store got it
start way back on the original Xbox
where you could download a small
selection of retro arcade games but it's
a central feature of the xbox 360 a lot
of people thought that the 360 s biggest
launch title was the ten-dollar
downloadable shooter geometry wars xbox
live arcade now plays host to over a
hundred different games from puzzle
quest to penny arcade adventures
Microsoft has a reputation for
controlling their service with an iron
grip they carefully pick and choose the
games they want they're even going to
start taking games off the service that
aren't performing up to expectations and
they have very small file size limits so
developers are limited to the kinds of
games they can make but Microsoft's
tight control does have benefits for
consumers every game has a demo so you
can try everything for free before you
buy it and remember when you're
downloading a game you can't trade it
back into the store so demos are crucial
xbox live arcade is good but it's not
quite where it needs to be I give it a
B+ for now than a C for potential since
Microsoft doesn't want to let the free
market figure itself out and let
developers put any game they want onto
the service there's an old saying that I
just made up that goes like this if even
Nintendo is doing something there's got
to be money in it so you know that
digital delivery is the future when
Nintendo's president is getting all
misty eyed about indie talent and the
democratization of game development
there it's cash to be ad for the first
year of wiis life games onto
man was limited to virtual console where
you could buy retro games from
Nintendo's history as well as plenty of
games from its former competitors like
Sega Genesis and neo geo right now there
are over 200 games on Virtual Console
although they're not releasing them as
fast as they used to they've gone from
four games a week to about one or two in
great part that's because Nintendo has
unveiled we where its download channel
for original games nintendo themselves
are taking a backseat and letting indie
developers have the spotlight some of
the standout hits include defend your
castle a version of the popular flash
game and lost wins a clever platform
game in which you use the wiimotes
motion controls to make the wind blow
but we wear has some pressing issues
there are no demos no try before you buy
a nintendo has much more stringent size
requirements than microsoft does so
games are smaller and they have to be
because the wii only has about half a
gigabyte of storage for games and you
can't expand it so if you buy a lot of
wiiware games you have to delete your
old ones a lot i give wiiware of be for
now and a b- for potential nintendo has
a ton of games on the service far more
than their competitors but they need to
get a proper storage system in order and
then there was Sony much like Xbox Live
Arcade and we where I'm of two minds
about Sony's PlayStation Store on the
one hand Sony seems to have absolutely
none of the restrictions that microsoft
and nintendo do you can make games as
big as you want because every ps3 has a
big hard drive in fact sony has released
a few games on both blu-ray disc and
playstation store like Warhawk in this
way Sony is closer to the reality of
digital distribution than their
competitors are ya direct download is
going to be great for a little pick up
and play arcade games but it'll be just
as important for full-on big-budget
games the very same you'd get in the
stores and while microsoft and nintendo
were kind of looking
may be doing this in the future sony is
all over it right now so what's the
problem uh there is not very much on the
PlayStation stars so far in 2008 there's
only been like 10 games that's not a
long tail marketplace that's not even a
short head the area where Sony could
really go for volume classic PlayStation
1 games which are available by the
hundreds on the Japanese PlayStation
Store has been a total bust in America
where there's only a tiny handful what's
up with that so playstation store shows
a lot of promise and it's probably
really close to what we're going to be
using in 5-10 years from now i'm giving
it a C for now but an a for potential
let's see if they use it
you